foreign
[Music]
I shouldn't have started this episode
with a mouthful of food okay perhaps not
strictly the show's fault but someone's
getting punished for the meatball sub
with extra sauce that I'm still going to
eat but feel very weird about doing so
now also yeah yeah Huey got gooeyed but
what I'm really concerned about is this
circle did someone set something so hot
in the sink that it scorched the metal
did someone spill black paint on the
bottom of a coffee cup did the aliens
from arrival try to leave us a coded
message to end all war pain and famine
this is important sorry about all that
don't be stupid you did us a favor did
he though surely there was more Intel
they could have extracted from
translucent and as bad as his Escape
would have been for the crew Huey had
him by the balls well by the never mind
he had him cornered so did he have to
pull the trigger on the enhanced cavity
search Eva he goes with you or break
your legs false dichotomies translucent
skin need one burn though Where Are You
Gonna Stitch at homelander you can't
find it nowhere nowhere look if you want
homelander to find the remains so you
can send him a vague yet possibly
incriminating message that's fine but
don't make it out like this is your only
option the tracking device is out of the
picture and if it's just as invisible
skin you're worried about there are a
billion places you could hide it it's
invisible
come on in holy [__] that was quick this
office is huge so is Ashley just
perpetually waiting by the door in case
someone knocks it is fantastic you're
pulling through the roof why does
everyone seem so shocked that people
would dig it when a superhero protect
someone in need I guess you're all
cynical but cynicism and stupidity are
not the same thing now Small Town Iowa
girl casting Malcolm Barrett just to
pour Salt in My Better Off Ted wounds
this show rundown is a mess first off
based on how it's highlighted I think
the current topic would be NBA and soups
and then the topics would be progressing
downward but discount every SportsCenter
anchor ever here is clearly talking
about the race already speaking of which
why are tomorrow's big race event of the
century and super versus super all in a
row when they're covering the same thing
shouldn't the goal be to put as many
different things in the rundown to keep
people watching this progression tells
me nothing about why I should stick
around I just want to be teased properly
and finally does SportsCenter only cover
superhero topics now are there no
regular-ass Sports to cover where will I
get my cornhole filled okay I was lying
when I said finally because the [__]
continues on according to these numbers
Shockwave is over 30 miles per hour
faster than a train that's not a close
race Shockwave would have a mile on him
within the first couple of minutes and
finally of course news position I am
angry and I am throwing things my anger
is making me destroy everything it's
this keyboard's fault and these posters
ger anger cliche I have never told you
how much I hate sitting on that couch
staring at the TV like we're already
dead kids how much I [__] hate pizza
rolls now you love pizza rolls when I
was seven abandoning Your Love of pizza
rolls which means that you have cut in
line in front of everybody else in here
mother's milk is chastising these two
for not putting their names in a time
slot but he didn't exactly make this
easy for anyone if this clock is correct
and there's no reason to assume it isn't
ping time hasn't even started yet it's
11 A.M in the first time slots at 2 20
p.m at least hanging around here for
three hours until it's time to Ping
their pongs I'm actually making progress
with these boys yeah so I could see
perfectly timed fight is perfectly timed
to perfectly undermine mother's milk's
point with impeccable perfect timing
funny should mention making a difference
because we just dusted a soup butcher
waste everyone's time here by using
Nostalgia to convince Eminem to get back
into the game instead of just opening
with a piece of information he knows
will grab his interest he buries the
lead so far up his own ass that
translucents and visible bits are
twitching boom Clara everywhere
butcher says [__] diabolical cliche
and no that's not just because I enjoy
saying [__] diabolical that would be
a [__] diabolical reason to give a
sit out [__] diabolical I tells ya
this is about Becca isn't it of course
it's about [__] Becca why would I
even need to say this I don't even know
who Becca is or what happened to her but
the fact that mother's milk is known
butcher for years and butcher is still
hunting soups suggests that the thing
that's driving him still hasn't been
resolved this is just so the audience
knows it's about Becca's murder
kidnapping slash splattening or whatever
it would be different this guy all right
nice secrets and lies mother's milk
believes this or isn't self-aware enough
to recognize his own desire to believe
this and stay the [__] away with his
wife and kid you bringing Frenchie back
misquoting Justin Timberlake songs
finishing now I ain't seen him in years
mother's milk believes this or isn't
self-aware look I love this guy but he
is way more trusting than I think his
experience should allow do you think I
am some double O wanker Wing shaming
there's nothing wrong with going for the
double O butcher anything above a
quadruple might be a bit excessive but
it's like we're always saying you do you
as many times as you like you two knows
kiss somebody come yeah and they will
immediately make up despite tearing
chunks out of each other a few seconds
ago and nothing really changing or being
resolved since then other than the
show's desire for the boys to start the
boising also a TV show called The Boys
takes two episodes in 18 minutes to
actually the boys I don't care if this
is a camera or a microphone There's no
practical benefit to extending it by two
inches a couple extra inches can be
helpful in some situations but not from
this distance every desktop every Smart
TV in the house has a camera on it there
are currently five smart TVs in my house
and none of them have camera built into
them you liar and yes this was just a
way to brag that I have five televisions
how else am I so supposed to watch drag
race while I'm in the shower and we can
get you all the way up to 1000 Mbps why
didn't he just say a gigabyte per second
instead of this 1000 Mbps BS it feels
like this was Huey's attempt to Blind
pop claw with science and we're supposed
to believe he's patronizing enough to
think this would work I mean it does
work but it shouldn't have worked and
look it just sounds dumb and I hate it
setting your desktop wallpaper for
ultimate expositional story impact no
recycling bin is ever empty ever that's
just the rules and if you want to prove
me wrong feel free to send a screenshot
to I just emptied my recycling bin and
took a screenshot to prove a point to
some guy on the internet at I don't
believe you.com having a spindle of
burnable discs in the year of Our Lord
2019. this kid is
Huey pulls off the spying through
webcam's plan far too easily and that's
what I'm choosing to believe so that I
can continue on safe in the knowledge
that my privacy is real while I watch
drag race in the shower
excuse me bud setting your surprise
hallway encounters for ultimate
expositional story impact this
minute-long fight scene has over 50 Cuts
in it including some repeated frames
which I completely understand
considering the bats are bending like
Rubber Chickens on every swing honestly
they might as well have used Rubber
Chickens as much of a joke as this
training fight is also other than giving
me vertigo what is this edited to death
scene doing for Maeve I'm assuming this
is some sort of training situation but
why she has super strength is
invulnerable to most forms of harm and
[__] fly so how is a bit of wrestling
with three mortal men helping her owner
craft yui how's the beeping as the
beeping Huey Huey Frenchy Butchy milky
why don't you just tell me where the V
is please not knowing where your
girlfriend's V is what the hell is
compound V well it starts as a bit of a
McGuffin to drive the plot but then
becomes the central storyline whose use
and effect changes as the story needs it
to evolve oh was that not what you meant
yeah whatever it was he was Juiced on it
when he murdered Robin I think you mean
manslaughtered Robin words are important
Huey
translucent huh how the [__] did you
pull that off he [__] didn't it was
Frenchy's idea why are we all pretending
that it was Huey's genius that killed
translucent the last thing I ever said
to Robin was don't you ever besmirch
Billy Joel that was the last thing that
she heard before she burst into pieces
and it was funny and you were laughing
together look clearly it was traumatic
for you but it's not like you were
cussing her out right before she
disintegrated and she died immediately
so there was no pain or anything get
over yourself man shoehorning puns
of a thousand miles per hour does he
because earlier ESPN said he clocked at
exactly the speed of sound which is
about 770 miles per hour I know Sports
people my friend Justin knows the warp
of every first baseman in the American
League down to the second decimal I
thought the vorp was an alien race on
one of those space Trek shows my point
is sports people don't mess up stats not
putting your talent under their own
poster look when the line gets this big
the poster helps you understand who
you're actually in line for and prevents
that awkward moment when you realize
you're in the wrong person's line and
then have to shuffle into the back of
the correct person's line where you
still have to eventually make eye
contact with a person whose line you're
originally in when they realize they
aren't the person you came to see not
that that's ever happened to me ever
using your hand instead of the built-in
zipper
[Music]
using AFS shorthand when your typing
makes sense but it's the same amount of
syllables when set out loud as so you're
not saving any time and I know for a
second believe it's because this [__]
gives AF about swearing in public if I
ever really thought that you've fallen
for someone else I just
don't think I can handle it one note
sociopathic homelander is my least
favorite homelander The Saga of the
shoddiest sports show summary conceived
continues as somehow since arriving at
the event Shockwave has managed to lose
time on his season best and a train has
managed to improve both his personal and
season best times that's impossibly
impressive Annie Annie Annie hi Huey
conveniently noticing that Starlight is
Annie the fact that they've conveniently
met before and that all of this
conveniently happens just as Frenchy is
about to be exposed is really [__]
funny actually I love Frenchy but it's
still really convenient too
why would the team assume was there in
the first place a train was clearly
being secretive about it so why would he
have left it in the [__] locker room
that anyone working with lock can
apparently get into it was 14 seconds
ago in Showtime that they left the
locker room door in there now already
seated with beers and nachos and this
sentence for rubbing my face in every 40
minute nacho line in every Sports
ballpark of every sports ball game ever
oh cool they're using the microphones
with the create static before shutting
off button I should probably get back do
you know before they set a search party
for me then why did you order a full
Pint of [__] beer Pippin they come in
halves you know I know you're you and
everything but if you ever just wanted
to you know get would you like my number
ah yes all it took was the power of
boners to help Huey clueless and bemused
over here to move on from his recently
deceased Billy Joel besmirching
ex-girlfriend he must have shut up today
we missed the boys but fortunately for
you Mother's Milk will choose this
moment to check cameras while pop claw
also chooses this moment to whip out the
stash of v and yes I know it's because
mm already suspected the red bag was a
drug stash but it's still all of the
convenient afbs that this worked out so
perfectly I'm out of here I'll check in
later what is going on here why is he
keeping the secret okay maybe he doesn't
want to get their hopes up but that's
[__] dumb I won't give a [__] if he's
wrong they'll just be happy for the lead
especially since he [__] tells them
in about 10 minutes anyway dramatic
secret is dramatic for no other reason
than to be dramatic
's gonna see about a girl everyone
accepts this answer just a reminder 371
meters a second is about 830 miles per
hour so once again that over 1000 miles
per hour announcer was full of sh also
it's just one [__] lap okay I'm not
expecting them to run a marathon but
that was done in just over a second you
couldn't have made the Run 10 laps and
stretch a [__] out a bit this is a lot
of effort for just one second of fun
wait what is it complaint sounds so
familiar pop claws eyeballing a vile of
V like is made of Snickers well there's
milk eats his stickers strangely when
did you last see Sports coverage that
didn't plaster stats upcoming games and
unless Vaught owns ESPN a load of
advertisements all over the screen
there's no way you'd be seeing this
amount of free screen on an event this
big hey Boca Mr Lutz um call I'm just
here for the rent porn video starts with
a landlord dropping by to collect rent
cliche or so I've heard well I wasn't
banking on getting two videos worth of
mileage out of that completely rectum
joke but here we are and there she sits
being surprised after you crunch
someone's head between your bare thighs
also misunderstanding the proper
procedure for getting head he was dead
already that's
so you can cross the street run off full
flights of stairs in 10 seconds like
some soup can you butcher would be
[__] diabolical at TV sins you still
ain't twig it's the one weakness they
all got their reputations sure that in
internal combustion enemas of course
smart actually very smart are we sure
about that homelander can't see through
zinc so sure the zinc box makes sense
but why throw it in the ocean instead of
burying it underground somewhere but
also it's complete bull sharks that a
porpoise would have just happened on
this box and thought to tell the Deep
about it that's right I'm sitting in
this closing reveal for being both too
dumb and too smart at the same time
because that's my superpower
foreign
sorry about all that I may throw up on
you be right back
[Applause]
hello I'm fine with my old outfit no
caps excuse me knock it I'm Bruce Nolan
for Eyewitness News back to you [__]
you broke your little ships I have never
told you how much I hate sitting on that
couch staring at the TV like we're
already dead the only one that's good
you're being a child that came to
Charlton Heston and not a chartered
accountant well you look like one you're
quasi-evil you're semi-eble you're the
margarine of evil you're the diet coke
of evil just one calorie not evil enough
clean your toes with my tongue
it's here for my boy a train
all right
go [__] yourself San Diego when you're
talking about how much you hated your
job you meant you meant this job
well have fun with your terrible jobs I
gotta go clean the executive conference
room and eat some Lobster ravioli peace